[Music]
calling all Autobots roll out
whoever I'm not driving
[Applause]
[Music]
slow down
this is probably a lot for you huh
[Music]
all right
who are you
are you why are you hunting for the key
yo Donkey Kong stay away from my friends
oh Mirage don't worry you boys got this
strange
hey over here kitty kitty
stand down
I won't ask a second time
we are in the middle of the war
[Music]
we have one last hope
maximals
above the face of all living things
but we have a chance
Transformers rise of the beasts June 9th
Optimus Prime will face Extinction
who are you
we are the maximals and we have the
power to fight what's coming
let's end this
[Music]
for centuries Our Kind has stayed hidden
on Earth
the darkness has found us again prime
about the fate of all living things
Unicron is coming
[Music]
back up Oh I thought we were boys
you want it
not a human here I'm nobody I ain't even
seen nothing I'm not even seeing
anything right now
this is not our war
Optimus we must trust each other to
protect the home we all share
how big can this guy be uh he eats
planets so like way bigger than a planet
in the end
everything you cared for
will be consumed
maybe there's another way to save our
home
never faced anything like this
let them come
thank you
yo Noah Take the Wheel
it's about the Epic
it's about to be crazy
this is about to be epically crazy
in chronological order this is the
second Transformers movie that takes
place during the 90s shortly after
Bumblebee
find a kid struggling with I was able to
provide for his family my character
noise ex-military and I feel like I'm
failing at every turn
then I meet Mirage
[Music]
Pete Davidson is it was a mirage he's
kind of like the rebellious Autobot you
looking good man
there you go now we're friends
Elena works at the Museum she's
investigating something which brings
Noah into her life who are you uh
janitor really and that kind of opens a
whole new world for her
going this crazy Journey with the
Autobots we meet the maximals
we meet the next level of villains how
big can this guy be uh he eats planets
so like way bigger than a planet
action there's humor stranger danger and
there's a lot of Hearts they're going
against their biggest Nemesis effort
they've never based anything like this
before let them come
[Music]
relax a mirage remember
thank you
[Music]
to stand down I'm not the one to fear
Pride
there is a Darkness coming
yeah
yes
it was all a dream
whoever I'm not driving
away
of all the threats
from both your past
and future
you've never faced anything like this
let them come
and if you don't know
oh he's here
[Music]